et si les modes de déplacement doux ont
conquis les villes c'est un peu plus
rare dans les campagnes nous sommes à
vous un petit village dans le Sud
Touraine c'est ici depuis sa maison que
Gaétan prépare sa tournée de livraison
de pain c'est une centaine de kilos
qu'il tractent avec son vélo depuis
maintenant 3 ans
[Musique]
un choix de vie ou le temps et la vraie
richesse c'est une décroissance choisie
parce que je suis persuadé que
décroissance il y aura et on a deux
possibilités soit la soit la subir soit
la choisir et voilà j'aime autant
choisir et Gaëtan livre aussi bien des
particuliers que des commerces qui font
office de dépôt de pain mais aussi des
entreprises qui veulent du bon pain pour
leur salarié
salut
ça va
déjà parce que le pain est très bon
première chose deuxième chose c'est un
pain bio et puis le mode de livraison
nous a paru très en phase avec avec
l'entreprise et puis avec le
la façon de travailler si le vélo peut
surprendre en territoire rural Gaëtan et
pourtant très bien accueilli avec
beaucoup de bienveillance le vélo ça
enfin je fais pas mal de voyages en vélo
aussi il y a toujours ce côté où tout le
monde se reconnaît un petit peu dans le
vélo on a tous fait du vélo on sait tous
en faire un minima et non c'est un
accueil qui est très positif on demande
souvent combien de temps tu mets pour
faire la tournée en fait je mets
un peu plus de 4 heures donc ce qui est
ça fait c'est parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de temps qui est passé à discuter avec
les gens et c'est quelque chose que
j'aime qui est fatigant à la fin de la
journée je suis je suis fatigué mais je
suis agréable les livraisons ont lieu
toute l'année qu'ils vantent ou qu'il
pleuve donc si vous passez à vous vous
serez ou demander votre pain